Du latin ! J'ai fait 3 ans de collège au latin !
... 3 ans de latin au collège !
Allez... Super
Bah du coup je te le dis pas !
C'est bien... C'est bien là ?
J'adore ça
(McFly) J'adore ça (Florence) Oh, une p'tite gifle, ça serait bien une p'tite gifle
Alors, vous aviez raison... c'est moche
[rires]
J'ai fait 3 ans de co-
DE LATIN AU COLLÈGE
Bonjour à tous, on va revenir sur ce qui s'est passé pour moi en 2018
qui était une année assez dingue avec plein de gros projets
Et à la fin on va aussi parler de ce qu'il va se passer pour 2019
Re-déroulons l'année, c'est parti !
On commence l'année avec le top 10 des jeux de l'année 2017
Voilà, c'est le petit clip qu'on a essayé d'instaurer avec Lucas (Squeezie)
Voilà, je suis un peu dans le rap game
C'est pas vrai du tout.
Et on va bien évidemment essayer de faire un top 10 des jeux de l'année 2018
Ce sera sur la chaîne Bigorneaux & Coquillages
Et on arrive au premier gros gros gros projet sur ma chaîne de l'année
C'est le court-métrage "Lunaire"
qui a été réalisé par Raphaël Descraques ; on a écrit l'histoire ensemble, c'était fou
Voilà c'était plusieurs jours de tournage, c'était un peu le premier court-métrage un petit peu dramatique aussi
Moi je suis très content de ce court-métrage-là
et de la diffusion en avant-première dans une salle de cinéma, au Max Linder à Paris
C'était absolument dingue de pouvoir vous projeter ce court-métrage dans des conditions pareilles.
Je suis ravi de ce projet, de toutes les collaborations et de ce que ça raconte
Parce qu'en fait c'est un truc assez intime
C'est une relation fraternelle que j'ai un petit peu vécu que j'ai mis dans cette histoire-là
Et merci aussi à tous les fans arts !
On a eu plein de petits dessins assez fous sur sur ce court-métrage-là
Donc je pense que l'année commence plutôt bien
Vous pouvez revisionner si l'envie vous en prend, avec un bouton ici qui s'affiche
On repart ensuite sur du sketch un petit peu plus classique
Puisque c'est l'invention du corps humain mais avec du guest de qualité
Madame Foresti, qui nous a fait un petit peu la patronne des réunions de conception du monde
Elle a été géniale, elle est venue aux répets, elle a écrit avec nous...
Merci Florence, merci à Alison (Alison Wheeler), à Julien (Julfou), à Mcfly (Mcfly & Carlito)
J'espère que ce sketch vous a plu, et peut-être qu'il y en aura d'autres, qui sait ?
*Who knows ?*
En parlant de langues étrangères
Hein, mon sketch sur les langues étrangères
Y'a Akim (Akim Omiri) qui a participé à cette vidéo notamment
Une chaîne YouTube c'est bien, pourquoi ne pas en avoir une deuxième ?
C'est pour ça qu'on a relancé avec Lucas "Cyprien gaming", que vous connaissez maintenant sous le nom de "Bigorneaux & Coquillages"
On a tout remis en question sur cette chaîne-là
On fait un peu moins de gaming, il est vrai
Mais on fait plus de petits délires, et surtout on a un nouveau studio
On fait plein de petits concepts de... à la con
Du genre on fait des tours de magie, on teste des véhicules de merde
Voilà, en tout cas c'est une chaîne qui nous, nous amuse énormément
Il faut juste trouver du temps pour pouvoir faire des vidéos, ça c'est le plus compliqué
Parce qu'on est des gens occupés, on est des youtubeurs
Et y'a plein de nouvelles vidéos prévues pour Bigorneaux & Coquillages pour l'année 2019
Donc vous pouvez rejoindre la chaîne bien évidemment
D'ailleurs, je vais parler souvent de fan art mais y'a eu plein de fans arts incroyables sur Bigorneaux & Coquillages
Merci à tous ceux qui ont participé
Ça me fait penser qu'on a sorti une petite boutique en ligne avec des produits Bigorneaux & Coquillages, qui s'appelle "Crustacés"
Et tous nos bénéfices revont à l'association "Cékedubonheur"
qui œuvre pour le quotidien des enfants dans les hôpitaux
Donc voilà, si vous voulez être "crustacés comme jamais", vous avez le lien dans la barre dans la description, et ça aide aussi les enfants dans les hôpitaux
Un court-métrage c'est bien gentil, pourquoi pas un deuxième ?
Et c'est là qu'on arrive à mon second court-métrage de l'année 2018
qui est "Dessine-moi un alien", qui est un court-métrage très particulier pour moi
parce qu'en fait il a été écrit assez rapidement
Voilà, c'est un peu comme une grosse blague mais avec beaucoup de préparation
Des dessins préparatoires sur l'alien, il a été construit pendant des semaines
On a repéré des lieux, on a aussi un cast incroyable avec les enfants, Isabelle Nanty
On est à l'opposé de Lunaire, puisque Lunaire c'est un truc un petit peu cérébral
Là, on est dans du bon gros débile
Ludovik a été parfait à la réalisation là-dedans d'ailleurs
Un gros gros kiff et j'ai adoré incarner un rasta blanc
Bah oui, je veux dire je porte si bien le bouc
Et puis j'ai fumé mon premier faux pétard
Hé, bientôt 30 ans euh... faut tester de nouvelles choses
C'est un faux joint avec du thé à l'intérieur
Ne fumez pas...
Trop.
Avec Squeezie, on part à Los Angeles pour le salon du jeu vidéo, comme chaque année
Et là on a fait des petits vlogs donc c'était cool, on a fait du surf, on a fait plein de choses
On arrive à l'été, voilà, les gens posent leurs vacances; et moi, qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ?
Pendant des semaines, j'ai préparé la saison 2 de l'Épopée Temporelle
10 épisodes d'une dizaine de minutes
Avec des trucs assez incroyables, à écouter tranquillement les pieds dans l'eau, ou chez vous, où vous voulez
C'était génial de faire, bien sûr, cette saison 2 avec encore plus de comédiens, avec encore plus de musique avec mes auteurs incroyables
qui sont Navo (Bruno Muschio), Yacine (Yacine Belhousse) et François (François Descraques)
Et bien sûr, pour terminer cette deuxième saison, on a sorti un coffret collector
Avec les deux saisons en CDs, plus des stickers, un livret, etc
que vous pouvez vous procurer sur narmol.fr, ils sont tous dédicacés parce que c'est un objet collector
Et je veux pas spoiler mais y'aura d'autres choses autour de l'Épopée Temporelle
Il faudra être un petit peu patient; ce sera pas nécessairement une série audio, je ne peux pas en dire plus
'fin si, je pourrais, mais j'ai pas envie, voilà
[Rires]
Je vous laisse un petit peu la surprise, voilà
L'Épopée Temporelle risque de revenir sous une forme un petit peu étonnante
Maintenant on arrive à la rentrée, en septembre, et là je mets ma plus belle perruque pour le sketch "Les instagrameuses" avec Audrey Pirault
Voilà, c'est une suite de sketches avec des influenceuses qui essayent de survivre en ce monde d'influence
C'était très amusant à faire, et puis avec Audrey ça s'est très bien passé
Big up aussi à Luciole qui m'a aidé à écrire les sketches
D'ailleurs, vous pouvez rejoindre les comptes Instagram de Alice et Zoé si vous voulez en savoir plus sur leurs vies
Elles vont revenir cette année
avec de nouveaux sketches
Deux court-métrages, ça va. Un troisième, c'est beaucoup mieux !
C'est pour ça qu'on arrive au troisième court-métrage qui s'appelle "La Science de l'Amour"
qui a été écrit et réalisé par Timothée Hochet, et c'est un projet qui me tient énormément à coeur
parce que c'est le premier projet dramatique sur ma chaîne réellement
C'est une histoire de nouvelles technologies et d'amour
On est sur un registre et des thèmes que je n'aborde jamais sur ma chaîne
Donc c'est vraiment de la grosse nouveauté, c'est un peu ça passe ou ça casse
Même je me suis dit "peut-être que les abonnés vont pas trop comprendre"
En tout cas, moi j'ai adoré faire ce projet-là
Bravo à toute l'équipe
J'étais très très agréablement surpris des retours, voilà y'en a plein d'entre vous qui ont beaucoup aimé
Je pense continuer un petit peu dans cette direction
à créer des histoires de plus en plus ambitieuses
Et si vous l'avez pas vu, bah vous pouvez cliquer juste là
pour découvrir "La Science de l'Amour", ou si vous regardez le Making-Off
y'a plein de petites astuces qu'on vous montre
On avance sur un nouveau projet, qui n'est pas un projet internet
Vous avez, j'espère, entendu parler de ça, mais j'ai sorti y'a 3 ans ma bande-dessinée qui s'appelle Roger et ses humains, que j'ai écrite
Vous étiez très nombreux à me demander la suite, ça m'a pris du temps
Mais voilà, début janvier jusqu'à la moitié de l'année, j'ai écrit
bah la suite de Roger et ses humains, le tome 2
On est allé encore un peu plus loin dans la bande-dessinée avec plus de pages, plus d'aventures, plus de décors, plus de blagues, plus de tout
Vous pouvez vous la procurer, il y a aussi un coffret avec deux tomes avec un paper toy à l'intérieur
à construire soi-même, ce genre de choses
J'en suis très content
Il y a le tome 2, mais aussi le dessin-animé "Roger et ses humains"
Voilà, c'est un format court où je fais la voix de Roger
Et je suis très content de bosser dessus
Et la suite des épisodes va arriver cette année, si vous êtes patients
Bon là, ça va en terme de court-métrages, de tout ça on va se calmer
Pas du tout
Un quatrième pour terminer l'année
Un petit peu plus court, certes, mais un court-métrage que j'apprécie particulièrement, puisque c'est moi qui l'ai réalisé entièrement
Ça s'appelle "Fais un vœu", c'est très simple, c'est juste ce qui se passe dans la tête d'un petit garçon qui grandit
et voir comment ses rêves évoluent
Y'a des blagues à l'intérieur, mais pas que
C'est un truc un petit peu complexe, que je voulais raconter depuis un petit moment
Comment être fidèle à ses rêves et en même temps apprendre à évoluer
Voilà, ça parle de ça
Et merci beaucoup pour l'accueil que vous avez fait pour mon dernier court-métrage de l'année, "Fais un vœu"
que vous pouvez visionner ici, tout de suite, si vous voulez
On s'approche des fêtes de fin d'année, j'ai fait une petite vidéo avec Bouygues Telecom
où en fait je reproduis des vieilles photos de moi enfant
avec toute une équipe pour reconstruire les décors, les costumes
J'ai l'air totalement ridicule, est-ce que c'est pas ça aussi le métier de youtubeur ?
Je vous le demande
Si, si, c'est ça
Et on termine l'année avec le retour des pubs versus la vie, avec Natoo
Voilà, c'est toujours un peu fun à faire, de reproduire des pubs totalement absurdes
Peut-être qu'il y en aura d'autres, on sait pas ! On sait pas, c'est la surprise !
Bien évidemment, j'ai participé à de petites vidéos à gauche à droite, chez Mcfly & Carlito
Je sais, on a perdu, il faut arrêter de m'en parler, ça me stresse énormément cette histoire de théâtre et tout, ok ?
J'ai fait une apparition aussi dans une vidéo du joueur du grenier, dans le clip de Pomme (À Peu Près)
Pomme, qui a fait la musique de fin du court-métrage "Lunaire", tout est lié !
On vous dit pas tout
Je suis un reptilien
J'ai aussi participé au Téléthon Gaming pour lever des fonds
Et si je devais faire un petit bilan de l'année 2018, c'est surtout que j'ai fait des projets qui me tiennent énormément à cœur
et beaucoup de court-métrages, au final j'ai fait 8 court-métrages en tout sur ma chaîne
et y'en a 4 qui ont été faits cette année
Donc je pense que c'est quand même beaucoup. C'est beaucoup de travail, d'investissement
Mais c'est énormément de plaisir, plein de rencontres et plein de projets dont je suis très très fier
C'est un peu, pour moi, une année assez riche artistiquement on va dire
Voilà, j'ai l'impression de pouvoir créer ce qu'il me plait, tout en faisant aussi des sketches qui sont plus simples
comme "Les pubs versus la vie", "Les langues étrangères", enfin ce genre de choses qui sont très fun à faire
Mais artistiquement, j'aime bien aussi explorer d'autres choses
On arrive en 2019, quels sont les projets pour cette année ?
Déjà, il va y avoir un jeu mobile voilà ça fait plus d'un an qu'on travaille dessus c'est un jeu où tu crées un petit youtubeur
et tu dois améliorer un peu ses vidéos, sa chaîne YouTube, créer plusieurs chaînes
J'espère que ça va vous plaire, voilà, moi j'aime bien créer des jeux aussi
Vous avez vu le Nope Quizz par exemple, ou même Ta Mère En Slip le petit jeu mobile
Voilà c'est un truc qui est vraiment très fun à faire, mais c'est très très très long
Ça demande du temps
J'ai très hâte que ça sorte, voilà vous serez tenus au courant dès que ça arrivera
Je dévoilerai le nom, où le télécharger, tout ça etc, vous inquiétez pas
J'ai participé aussi à des tournages l'année dernière, par exemple pour la chaîne Inernet ou Yes Vous Aime
Donc voilà, ces projets-là vont arriver cette année
Mais quel sera le prochain gros projet sur ma chaîne YouTube ?
Et ben c'est un court-métrage, forcément, pas de surprise
Mais qui a une particularité puisqu'il sera tourné au Japon, à Tokyo plus précisément
C'est vraiment un rêve de faire ça parce qu'en fait j'adore ce pays et j'ai plein de choses à raconter
J'ai écrit l'histoire, je suis en train de former l'équipe, on prépare le tournage là-bas
Ce sera dans quelques semaines/quelques mois
J'ai envie de raconter plein de choses à l'intérieur, parler des différences entre la France et le Japon
mais aussi les rêves d'artistes, de tout ça
Bref je veux pas vous dévoiler le scénario, mais j'ai très hâte de le tourner et de vous le montrer tout simplement
Mais y'a aussi plein d'autres choses qui vont arriver sur ma chaîne n'est-ce pas ?
Vous avez vu, la suite des instagrameuses, le dessin-animé Roger et ses humains qui va arriver, et plein d'autres projets
Et j'ai aussi, derrière, des trucs qui sont encore plus fous, plus gros
qui demandent plus de travail et d'argent et de tout ça
mais je peux pas trop trop vous en parler
Si un jour vous voyez d'autres projets qui arrivent c'est normal, c'est parce que je travaille dessus
En tout cas, merci beaucoup pour cette année 2018, merci de me suivre et de me faire confiance dans tous ces projets
Et moi j'ai très hâte de faire plein de choses aussi pour l'année 2019
Donc je vous dis à très vite !
*Clap!*
Dinosaure!
Alors par contre, qui...
Qui ? Qui ? Oui, j'y viens...
Qui ?
[rires]
Élie Semoun...
"Qui?"
Aaah
Pendant quatre jours, on poste des photos de plage... qu'on trouve sur.. in..ternet  (Suis mon doigt)
- Mieux vaut deux fois qu'une - Ta gueule.
Ah ben tu vois ? J'ai la poisse avec les accessoires
Coupez !
Tiens, c'est ta fiche de paye
Putain
Oh ! Putain...
Ça fait mal !
Ok.
T'as entendu le bruit ?
Ça va ?
Ouais
Connard
Ah oui petite rougeur
J'ai pas de livre les enfants
Tiens, prends le mien
[cri étrange]
Je crois qu'il ramener Cyprien chez lui
Il doit quitter Alice
Attendez! Si...
Et pourquoi pas pour les hommes ?
On comprend pas ce que je dis !
Là non, la première fois oui hein
Un jour, on va le faire ce tour du monde
Et consommer un maximum de drogues
Là y'a "coït", là je crois
Aaah non, ça rentre pas coït, on enlève
Je vais jouer à Fortnite moi aussi
Ok, coupez !
Pour mieux se comprendre soi-même
aAAHAHAHAh
Bonsoir
Arrête le !
Mais reviens !
Mais prends moi dans tes bras un petit peu, je sais pas moi !
Me touche pas !
C'est toujours cette ambivalence que t'as Alice qui est compliquée à gérer pour les gens autour
Photo quand même
Quand même !
Quand je dis toutes les couleurs, me sortez pas du violet non plus hein
On n'est pas...
On n'est pas dans les années 80-
Bon bref, j'ai pas de chute
Ouais, non je comprends